[Music]
on this Tuesday night in Gaza the dead
go uncounted hospitals caught in the
crossfire now digging Mass Graves the
situation in fact is getting worse and
worse those who have escaped Gaza and
made it back to Canada both of us
Israeli people and Palestinian people
they like to live in peace plus Canadian
peace activist Vivian Silver's final
message to friends as Hamas gunman
stormed her home arrested the action UK
police are taking after a pro hockey
player died from a slash to the neck
plus flying off into the sunset the
prime minister's aging plane finally
retires global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us we are following events in
Gaza tonight for the first time the
Israeli Defense Forces confirm they have
moved into gaza's largest Hospital which
is filled with hundreds of patients and
staff including babies in a statement
the IDF said tonight it is conducting
what it calls a precise and targeted
operation in a specific area of the
hospital it didn't specify where it says
the intent is that no harm is caused to
civilians it says are being used by
Hamas as human Shields Israel has
maintained Hamas has its command and
control center beneath elifa Hospital
something doctors and staff say they
know nothing about today do Without
Borders which has staff at that hospital
said thousands of civilians medical
staff and patients are trapped in
hospitals and other locations Under Fire
in Gaza City they must be protected and
afforded safe passage if they wish to
leave also today for the first time
Pentagon and White House officials said
the US has Intelligence that shows Hamas
uses hospitals in Gaza including the
alifa hospital to conceal and support
their military
operations we do have information
that Hamas and the Palestinian Islamic
Jihad uses some hospitals in the Gaza
Strip including the alifa hospital um as
a way to conceal and support their
military operations and hold
hostages right now the living cannot
Escape that hospital and there is
nowhere to bury the dead there are
reports Mass graves are being dug
outside gaza's largest hospital again a
warning some of the pictures in our
stories are disturbing Danielle Hamin
begins our coverage
tonight the first rainfall in Gaza since
the War Began it doesn't take much to
make the children
[Applause]
smile but everybody else knows what the
start of the rainy season could
mean the prospect of flooding would
almost certainly overwhelm the sewage
system and disease would
spread this on top of 39 days of air
strikes and
counting in hospitals that are still
functioning the flow of incoming
patients is incessant water now is a
very challenging you know thing it used
to be in such you know emergency
situation 15 liter per day per person
the available water now is 1 to three
liter per person per day and most of
that water is not really suitable for
drinking or for
cooking Israeli forces claim Hamas has
lost control over Gaza City they say the
group's Command Center is located under
the largest hospital in The
Enclave the Moore get Al shifa hospital
no longer works the bodies more than
120 are piling
up on Tuesday the civilians trapped in
the hospital complex are set to have dug
a mass grave within the grounds of the
compound the very best men there and we
are sure all kinds of infections and dis
will be transmed from that one today we
had a little bit of rain rainy weather
in the morning and then this s was
really horrible no one could even open a
window or just walk around within the
corridors with this very
bad Israel has urged civilians in the
north to flee South where it's not much
safer suan Abad in Kan Yunis who is deaf
describes how his house was bombed seven
of his children were with him in the
room there are fears in some parts of
the Arab world that Israel is trying to
drive Palestinians out of Gaza fears
that are Amplified when far-right
members of Benjamin netanyahu's
government make comments such as this
one that Israel will no longer be able
to accept the existence of Gaza as an
independent entity and that Palestinians
should agree to voluntarily immigrate to
to other countries that was a quote from
the Israeli Finance
Minister Donna Danielle in Jerusalem
thanks an Israeli Canadian woman is now
known to have died in the October 7th
attacks by Hamas it was thought that VI
Vivian silver was taken hostage but
forensics confirmed she was killed
inside her home today Global News spoke
to some of those closest to her about
how even in her final moments she was
focused on peace Mike Armstrong
reports
just 3 days before the October 7th
attacks Vivian silver was at an event in
the West Bank held by a group she helped
found but a lifetime spent in the
pursuit of
Peace was ended by the violence she was
trying to prevent it's it's absurd it's
absurd that she was taken and over she
she was murdered y brow worked for years
alongside silver at women wage peace on
the morning of the attacks as Hamas
gunman entered kabut ber silver was
hiding in her home but with her
phone now this is another kabut but it's
exactly what was going on in
ber while it was happening silver was
updating friends including brow silver
could hear gunfire and at some points
people in her house she told us say it's
very scary but it's okay and it's
helping me to be H with you on WhatsApp
and uh and she had a wonderful sense of
humor so uh she also she was laughing a
little bit about it the even in the
middle of that yes now with gunman
moving around the Kuts in between texts
silver took a call from an Israeli radio
station a host who knew her and knew how
close she lived to Gaza just a few
kilometers it appears to be her last
conversation she was sitting in her safe
room she was she said she told us that
she was sitting on the floor H probably
hiding
[Music]
now there was hope after silver
disappeared that she was still alive
that like some of her neighbors in this
video she was taken
hostage but when investigators went
through kibuts Berry and what was left
in the burnt out homes they found found
something in Silver's safe room not much
but enough to confirm it through DNA
there is nobody The Remains are burnt
the ashes it's
ashes what is left now are memories of a
mother silver had two sons and a
grandmother she had four grandchildren
and a fifth on the way
e but for her friends she has also left
inspiration
in that radio interview even with
bullets and Rockets ringing out she told
the host she still wanted to talk about
peace it's time it's time she said and
then she told the host they'd talk about
it again when everything was over Mike
Armstrong Global News Tel
Aviv optimism is in short supply in the
region right now though today the
American president said the families of
the more than 200 hostages held by Hamas
should be patient I've been talking with
the people involved every single day I
believe it's going to happen but I don't
want to get in detail what's your
message for the families hang in there
we're coming today tens of thousands of
people gathered on the National Mall in
Washington to demand the release of
those hostages and to show solidarity
with Israel as Jackson prco reports
people came from across the country and
from
Canada with heavy security from police
police and the National Guard tens of
thousands marched for Israel I'm here to
support everybody I love there is raw
anger over the October 7th attack 38
days and deep fear about what will
happen to hundreds of hostages held by
Hamas including Ora neutra's son om we
all must use the power that we have to
help bring om and all of the hostages
home
now the March was also meant to send a
message about Rising anti-Semitism with
incidents up more than 300% in the US
this year according to the
Anti-Defamation League Jews right now
are experiencing unprecedented levels of
anti-Semitism and hatred against Jews it
is really really scary fear has spread
across the border Ruthie wall is more
than one of 2,000 Jewish Canadians who
made the journey to be here we're not
going to stand for anti-Semitism in
Canada or in the US or around the world
down the state of
Israel not everyone is United the
civilian toll of Israel's military
campaign in Gaza has deepened division
over whether it's time for a ceasefire
we said they're killing a lot of
innocent uh Palestinian civilians but
they're also hurting Israel we're at War
our people have been attacked
brutally but in official Washington
support for Israel remains steadfast
thank you everybody clear to the
audience of thousands is that there's no
question Aid will continue to flow to
one of America's closest allies the
United States has always stood with
Israel and we will do everything to see
that that never ever
changes Jackson crosco Global News
Washington a salmonella outbreak in
Canada has been linked to raw dog food
it's very young children who are getting
sick Heather yuck West explains what
parents need to know and the dogs are
gring believed to help dogs with
digestive issues but your pet's raw food
diet could make your kids sick this is
pet food that has produced from raw from
raw animal protein so it hasn't been
cooked according to the public health
agency of Canada an outbreak of
salmonella infections linked to Raw pet
food and contact with cattle has made
dozens of people ill across Canada 40
cases have been identified across six
provinces the majority in Quebec and
onario
and the most susceptible population for
salmonella infection is obviously
infants you know below 5 years old
that's because Health Canada does not
test approve or regulate pet food in
this country problem is if a pet becomes
infected with salmonella from
contaminated food it can easily pass the
bacterial infection on to its owners if
people interact with those animals um
they can become sick Health Canada says
more than 40% of those sick in this
outbreak are under the age of five so
far 13 patients have been hospitalized
the strain of salmonella highly
resistant to antibiotics essentially
what happens is when you go to hospital
all they can do is basically rehydrate
you um rather than give you any drugs
and it can be a painful experience to
watch especially if you're a parent
health officials say people should not
feed their pets raw food especially when
there are small children in the home
Heather urex West Global News Calgary
there's another sign of the pain the
rising cost of living is causing
Toronto's annual who's hungry report
reveals one in 10 people now rely on
food banks twice as many as the year
before as Eric senson explains food
banks say they're at their Breaking
Point Bridget Martin is a volunteer but
also a client of the North York Harvest
Food Bank 15 years ago she was injured
on the job her benefits were eventually
cut off and food banks saved her my
income was not enough my rent was far
too hide and still with the food bank
and still without the food bank I could
not have done not have survived that
time what's different today is the
magnitude of the need more than $10
million wor the food will likely go
through this facility alone this year
Toronto has seen a 51% increase in food
bank visits the highest ever more than 2
and a half million visits so far this
year and that numberers expected to
exceed 3 million visits by the end of
2023 another difference many food Bank
clients today have jobs but earn too
little to keep up with the rising cost
of food and housing it's unacceptable
that one in four Food Bank clients spend
100% of their income on housing leaving
nothing for food clothing or
Transportation all levels of government
have to do more starting with the
federal government and the Canada
disability benefit 35% of all food bank
users have a disability the food bank
wants to see long-awaited federal
disability benefits actually delivered
by 2025 it wants the province's plan to
build 1.5 million new homes to include
300,000 affordable units and it wants
City Hall's plan to reduce poverty to
have funding attached there is plenty of
failure um from our institutions from
our leaders as I said at all levels and
across the ideological Spectrum um that
have driven us to uh where we are today
we want to belong somewhere we don't
want to be dis G and say for Bridget
Martin and so many more long-term
Solutions include incomes that keep up
with the cost of living but the
immediate fix for many comes down to
food banks which need support from
governments private sector and public
donations more than ever before Eric
senson Global News
Toronto coming up an arrest in the death
of a former NHL player in the
UK police in England have arrived
arrested a hockey player on suspicion of
manslaughter after the death of another
player American Adam Johnson his neck
was cut by a skate in the middle of a
game in Sheffield England the player has
not been charged yet Redmond Shannon
explains what's behind his arrest and
what might be the next
steps Sunday saw the first game back at
the Sheffield Arena since the death of
Adam Johnson at the venue with special
tributes for Nottingham's number 47 and
a fan Ovation in support of Sheffield's
Canadian defenseman Matt petgrave we are
not showing the exact moment but in a
game last month it was pet grave skate
that cut Johnson's neck on Tuesday
police investigating the incident
arrested a man on suspicion of
manslaughter but did not name him in a
statement South Yorkshire police said we
have been carrying out extensive
inquiries to piece together the events
which led to the the loss of Adam in
these unprecedented circumstances we
have been speaking to highly specialized
experts in their field to assist our
inquiries it is very rare for police to
lay criminal charges for sports
incidents in 2004 canu player Todd berzi
pleaded guilty to assaulting Colorado's
Steve Moore going right after Brasher
and he slashed him right in the head
four years earlier Marty murle of the
Bruins was convicted of assaulting the
Canucks Donald she they're going to have
to determine like in criminal law that
there is a what we call the Mena or the
intent of committing a crime um codified
under their criminal code police say the
man arrested remains in custody they
have asked for the public to refrain
from speculation on the case which they
say could hinder their investigation
Redmond Channon Global News
London still ahead the Bittersweet
feeling of Canadians who've escaped
[Music]
Gaza as the world watches what's
unfolding in Gaza there are some who are
lucky enough to tell the story of what
they endured there of the roughly 400
Canadians registered in Gaza 356 have
now escaped through the Raffa Crossing
into Egypt and as Tria isra reports
they're now safe in
Canada Pearson Airport the last leg of a
journey this husband and wife feared
they would not survive after a month
trapped in Gaza Palestinian Canadians
Amir and suar Yousef are safe in the
arms of their son they actually tried
for almost 2 weeks uh back and forth
back and forth they crossed the Rafa
border into Egypt then flew straight
home from Cairo but there's no escaping
their feelings of overwhelming loss my
big brother they killed they had truck
in my house house and they killed my big
brother hanni albet nii also got out of
Gaza the Ottawa father traveled there to
sell his family home when war broke out
my feeling when I crossed the border I
feel that I am born again he spent weeks
going house to house evading air strikes
my brother is in
wheelchair when we moved from first
place to the second place my nephew he
carry him in his back and we're running
Barefoot nothing you have nothing there
wherever they went they were surrounded
by death imagine every building get
bombed at people underneath
it just smell it when elbet nii finally
made it to the Rafa border he says bombs
were raining down the blood came out
from my ear he's relieved to be reunited
with his wife and four children but is
haunted by the hundreds of thousands of
gazin who can't leave like his brother
who does not have Canadian citizenship
really when I leftt border if left this
thanks God I am out but what about the
others Left Behind teria isri Global
News
Ottawa next the final farewell for the
prime minister's often problematic
plane farewells can be sad but not this
one a 30-year-old Air Force jet that has
been Canada's IP aircraft is getting a
new role it's carried royalty and prime
ministers and has had its fair share of
problems tonight our chief political
correspondent David Aken who has logged
many miles on that plane himself takes a
look back at its travels and troubles
the first thing to know about Canadian
Forces 01 seen here in its original
color is that it is no Air Force One no
Canada's pm has been flying around in a
very modest modified Airbus it was built
in 198 87 bought by Canada in 1992 used
from Canadian Airlines and then given a
new paint job in 2013 the plane is so
old it still had ashtrays in the
washrooms Brian Malon spent $56 million
to convert the plane though he never
flew in it Jean cretan dubbed it a quote
flying Taj Mahal he took out the VIP
items he never used it either as PM four
times a year it was Paul Martin who
first used the plane for official PM
travel and by then all the seating was
economy except for the Spartan VIP cabin
at the front
join here's Steven Harper in that cabin
with cretan Kim Campbell and Brian Mone
on the way to Nelson Mandela's funeral
where did all those VIPs sleep on the
long flight to South Africa well there's
only one bed in the cabin so at least
three of those xpms would have had to
sit and sleep in economy seats which
only barely reclined
there are no TVs at any passenger seat
Wi-Fi on board forget it there's not
even electrical outlets for passengers
it's been battered beat up and has often
broken down most recently stranding
prime minister Justin Trudeau in India
for an extra few days while the Air
Force waited for a part to fix it and so
we say goodbye to the old cfo1 and hello
to the new cfo1 that's one of them
behind me it's an Airbus 2 an
A330 bought used from from Kuwaiti
Airways it was built in 2015 modern
enough I'm told that there will not be
any ashtrays in the washroom Donna well
that's an important update David Aken at
ottawa's airport thanks that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Donna
freezen tonight's your Canada is the
unveiling of the new Looney at the Royal
Canadian Mint in Winnipeg it features
the face of King Charles III the first
Canadian coin with his Majesty's image
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye
[Music]
fight